dann fahren wir noch mal von vorn haben
würde ich sagen ja ja ich habe mal
fahren also alle die bei einfach medizin
sind viel spaß bei einem zweiten anfang
so halli hallo letzten blick so also er
herzlich willkommen auf dem live stream
von pixum zum thema
verschwörungstheorien genau jetzt immer
live auf klicks und wir hatten gerade
ein klitzekleines problem so jetzt höre
ich mich nur doppelt so 12 jetzt bin ich
mal gespannt mehr irgendwelche nein ich
habe ich meist verläuft machen wir den
wald wild aus den hasseler gerade eben
wieder angemacht
eigentlich habe ich den ausgemacht bei
mir ist der lautsprecher ausgeschaltet
so halten die live streaming auf klicks
um zum thema verschwörungstheorien und
bei einfach medizin wer von euch hat es
noch auf seinem kanal job nur du martin
ist immer noch da und themen hat auch
noch also auch noch bei themen von astro
comics tv herzlich willkommen
jetzt scheint es tatsächlich zu
funktionieren
computer sind auch nur menschen und wir
auch und ja ich habe gerade schon mal
gefragt beziehungsweise gesagt bevor wir
hier online waren ja
verschwörungstheorien ist etwas was uns
alle begleitet und mehr oder weniger
freiwillig weil ja eigentlich
beschäftigen wir uns ja mit theorien und
theorien sind bei uns eigentlich ja
wissenschaftliche thesen die dann in
mehreren untersuchungen immer wieder auf
die probe gestellt werden und dann
bestätigt werden oder eben ja abgewiesen
werden sie stimmen nicht das passiert
eben auch immer wieder
und nur wenn das passiert berichten wir
eigentlich drüber aber in der
diskussionen und jetzt auch auf youtube
im chat oder und das ist noch mal eine
ganz wichtige information
ihr könnt auch der link kommt jetzt im
chat auch auf youtube ihr könnt auch auf
disc ort diskutieren dort haben wir
einen server eingerichtet von essent
1054 da gehören wir nämlich alle zu wir
sind es 1054 kanäle ein wissenschafts
netzwerk mit kanälen wie und jetzt
stelle ich war vorher unten haben wir
jetzt muss die andere seite in die
andere seite weisen sonst passt das
nämlich nicht dauernd namen von astor
comics tv darüber ist martin von einfach
medizin auf der anderen seite markus von
neugier zone und da und darunter dr
wissenschaft tom aber noch ist kein
doktor aber das kann ja noch werden
ja und wir sind alle mit diesen themen
ständig konfrontiert und deswegen direkt
man meine frage in die runde also frage
an tom haben wir erstmalig fragen aber
dann hat es ist ich komme aber ich stehe
ich sehe mich hier raus ist alles genau
dem hast du schon mal eine
verschwörungstheorie glaubt ja
tatsächlich nicht so weit ich weiß weil
ich schon sehr früh angefangen habe und
ari um zu arbeiten wissenschaftliche
vorträge zahlt dann war ich immer so ein
bisschen eben keine ahnung ein falls an
den weihnachtsmann oder sogar osten
beispiel relativ immun gegen
verschwörungen zöge das ist ja schon mal
ein interessantes interessanter punkt
als kinder haben wir durchaus mal an die
eine oder andere verschwörungstheorie
geglaubt martinis bei dir meine ersten
berührungspunkte
damit waren tatsächlich in der schule
als einen klassenkameraden werde ich bis
dahin ganz grün freundet war und dann
tatsächlich auch später so in
verschwörungstheorien gesagt hatte was
ich in die zahl für den scherz echt
hielt sich dann aber herausgestellt hat
der glaubt ja aber selber glaube ich
habe ich bis auf weihnachtsmann
osterhase nie so wirklich an so etwas
glaubt markus wie es bei dir ich habe
immer eigentlich alles das geglaubt was
in den medien kam und vor allem damals
nine eleven war für mich schon erst die
erste verschwörungstheorie die auf mich
zukam
als ich davon gehört aber die medien
aber ich gedacht okay das muss alles so
stattgefunden haben wie es da gezeigt
wird aber in späteren jahren
wenn man sich dann genauer beschäftigt
und vielleicht kann der eine oder andere
youtuber anschaut das analysiert dann
kommt man drauf dass das auch relativ
plausibel
teilweise ist das dass das vielleicht
nicht ganz so abgelaufen sein kann
wissen in den medien gezeigt wurde
und diesmal kurz elena und information
und da kommen wir dann auch wirklich auf
diesen grad wo man herausbekommen kann
was ist wissenschaft und was ist
verschwörungstheorie natürlich bei nine
eleven da sind zwei flugzeuge das haben
wir alle sehen können in die beiden
world trade center geflogen aber es gibt
ein drittes gebäude und dazu gibt es und
das ist der punkt inzwischen gutachten
und das sind gut ab nahmen experten
gaben ist untersucht zum dritten gebäude
und da sind alle säulen gleichzeitig
kollabiert und das macht natürlich
skeptisch aber das hat nichts damit zu
tun dass mannschaft und
verschwörungstheorien eins und eins
zusammenzählen reicht nicht sondern es
müssen halt wirklich von fachleuten
gemachte untersuchungen sein und dann
muss es weitere untersuchungen geben die
diese untersuchungen entweder bestätigen
oder eben für falsch erklären und das
ist wissenschaft ein langer weg in dem
dann langsam erkenntnisse gewonnen
werden und manchmal werden sie gar nicht
gewonnen zum beispiel was heute noch
absolut es den weltkrieg da gibt es so
viele bücher über das thema und da nicht
alle zur gleichen zeit am selben ort
sein konnten ist das wird das
wahrscheinlich jetzt geht ist bei diesen
hast du schon mal eine
verschwörungstheorie glaubt also bei mir
war es so ich kann mich noch ziemlich
genau daran erinnern dass ich sowas von
überhaupt nicht gehört habe für mich war
das völlig neue verschwörungstheorien
was ist das und dann kam direkt das
erste youtube-video auf mich zu ich bin
also quasi opfer eines youtube-videos
geworden und dort wurde vor diesen chips
erzählt die den menschen ja reihenweise
implantiert werden
sollen um die kontrolle über die
menschheit zu erlangen
und bei mir was daneben so dass das für
mich völlig ungewohnt war so was zu
hören dass einem quasi informationen
vorenthalten werden
und ja so bin ich dann erstmal ziemlich
schockiert gewesen und musste
tatsächlich einige nächte darüber
nachdenken und dachte ist das jetzt
wirklich so ich hatte ja keine ahnung
ich bin das erste mal damit in kontakt
gekommen das heißt ja mich hat schon mal
so eine verschwörungstheorie erreicht
aber gut wir werden vielleicht später
noch mal gründlicher erfassen woran das
liegt warum man daran glaubt und ja wie
man auch relativ schnell darauf kommt
dass es vielleicht eben nicht der
wahrheit entsprach was man dann gesehen
hat das ist nämlich eigentlich gar nicht
so schwierig ich hab ja vielleicht hat
es ja eine oder andere gesehen in meinem
video rascheres theorien mit einer
wissenschaftlerin die zu dem thema
geforscht hat gesprochen und warum man
ich sag mal baum es menschen gibt die
gerne an verschwörungstheorien glauben
darüber forscht sie da gibt es auch
keine abschließenden ergebnisse aber zu
vielen anderen fragen die
verschwörungstheorien angehen
ja da gibt es da gibt es durchaus eben
erkenntnisse und das ist spannend sie
selber sprichst ja übrigens von
verschwörungs mythen weil eine theorie
deshalb eine wissenschaftliche these die
aufgestellt wird und dann ebenfalls
infiziert wird
und da kann ich doch mal eine
interessante geschichte erzählen die ich
so die ich so noch nicht ausführlich
erzählt habe zwar war ich mal
mittagessen mit meur von einem großen
privaten regionalsender
der auch eben ein riesen reichweite in
deutschland hat und er wusste das nicht
dass wissenschaft so funktioniert und
wenn man natürlich nicht weiß wie
wissenschaft funktioniert dann ist das
schwierig und das ist genau das prinzip
von wissenschaft sie sucht und
wissenschaftlern und anderen fachleuten
ein ewiger wettbewerb darum was ist die
wahrheit was stimmt und was stimmt nicht
und das ist das spannende ich soll
übrigens oder ich möchte einen riesen
dank aussprechen an eine youtuber der
eine großzügige spende über den superjet
geleistet hat nämlich der hat noch ein
ganz einfach zu merkenden namen der
heißt 44 6 11 63 74 61 72 20 53 74 72 61
63 67 65 vielen dank das dürfte kann
dass jemand übersetzen
ja das dürfte vielleicht auch etwas
anderes heißen aber ist es das ist
natürlich ganz toll wie wir freuen uns
alle alle kanäle übrigens wenn wir
mitglieder gewinnen können wenn leute
uns viel gucken viel werbung in den
videos gucken weil davon leben wir
schließlich und jetzt in den corona
zeiten ist das ein bisschen schwierig
aber ja dafür machen wir auch eine menge
und hier 45 wir leben glaube ich für die
wissenschaft und das ist genau der punkt
wir liegen für die wissenschaft und ja
das ist so ein bisschen die
schwierigkeit dass wir für die
wissenschaft leben und nicht für
irgendwas was man sich aus den fingern
saugt und ja was im zweifel nicht stimmt
und bevor ich ja jetzt was ich sehr
gerne tue wie wir übrigens alle ins land
komme wie begegnet ihr den
verschwörungstheorien also ich kann nur
sagen bei mir wenn ich über den
klimawandel
im video mache wenn ich über die erde
natürlich über dem mond apollo und so
weiter videos mache dann geht immer die
diskussion nur das ganz heftig wie ist
das bei euch
ich fange jetzt mal ganz anders an
random markus was hast du dazu stellung
ich hab gehört die kommentare die jets
durchgelesen
das ganze wiederholen wie begegnet ich
sag mal an verschwörungstheorien glauben
in meinem freundeskreis mainz zuletzt
oder lebt auf seinem kanal in den
kommentaren so in meinem hintern leute
die sagen keine ahnung den jupiter gibt
es nicht oder die mondlandung hat sich
ergeben oder oder oder
also da muss ich sagen beim einem kanal
dann hält sich das recht in grenzen
ich kann mir nicht erklären warum aber
vielleicht weil ich noch nicht so diese
themen flache erde mondlandung zum teil
letztes jahr warum ja auch den
livestream hatten soll zum 50 jährigen
jubiläum
da habe ich zwei videos zum thema
mondlandung gemacht aber sonst habe ich
eigentlich diesbezüglich keine
speziellen themen und deswegen hätte ich
bei mir echt den grenzen also muss man
echt sagen bin ich hochzufrieden gut
aber das wird noch passieren ich kann ja
das sagen ab der bestimmte reichweite
kommt das automatisch und ich glaube du
hast gerade empfiehlt auf den chat ich
habe gerade weg gemacht weil ich drum
problematisch 500 mal gehört da geht es
wahrscheinlich ab
deswegen war ich vorne auch sehr
abgelenkt weil wir haben ja jetzt auch
schon über 1000 zuschauer
ja und ich habe übrigens nicht falsch
gelegen
diese lange zahlenkombination sondern
unseren großzügigen spender heißt doctor
strange ja vielen dank also doctor
strange für die großzügige spende
ja martin bei dir ist es wahrscheinlich
öfter so dass gerade das thema
impfgegner gebracht dass du mit solchen
kommentaren zu tun hast ja tatsächlich
also auf meinem früheren kanal der
medizinstudent hatte ich ein zwei videos
eben gegen impfgegner oder fürs impfen
gemacht und da haben sich diese leute
schon sehr stark darunter gesammelt da
gibt es von bisher da gibt es die ganz
abgefahren
die von dir auch ganz viele sachen so
miteinander kombinieren viele glauben
überhaupt nicht an krankheiten
das ist einfach nur irgendwelche bösen
gedanken sind oder irgendwas da auch
irgendwelche teuflischen religiösen
sachen auch teilweise
genau die zeit die ganz abgefahren mit
denen dann wirklich auch nicht
diskutieren kann oder sollte also das
ist die reine zeitverschwendung
da schreibe ich auch nicht zurück und da
gibt es bisher aber zu den leuten die
sich bei bestimmten punkten nicht klar
sind einiges jetzt auf dem neuen kanal
mit auf ein fach medizin
ja also viele halt so corinna natürlich
weil ich da viele videos dazu gemacht
habe was tatsächlich hin und wieder sehr
anstrengendes weil bestimmten
verschwörungstheorien ein verschwörungs
mythen kleine wahre aspekte drin sind
aber vielleicht auch aufgrund der
vorwissen der einzelnen leute die so
ganz anders interpretiert sind also was
zb impfstoffe irgendwelche therapien
oder wie auch immer angeht oder der
unterschied zwischen einer studie mit
einem medikament beispielsweise im labor
in vitro ja mit zellkulturen und am
menschen ja was da die unterschiede sind
sehe ich meine zum beispiel im labor da
kann ich solche konzentration
wahrscheinlich von fast allem drauf
klein auf diese zellen bis das virus
stirbt menschen schaut ist halt leider
etwas anders und dann manchmal diese
sachen zu vermitteln dass durchaus
schwierig man muss sich dann auch
überlegen ob das einen dann die zeit
wirklich wichtig sind da ich sehe gerade
im chat der einer der klassiker beim
impfen dieses stammzellen von
abgetriebenen föten oder was da nicht
alles immer gesagt wird beim impfen
da gibt es einfach brutal vier ja nur
zur information du kennst dich da aus
stammzellen von abgetöteten töten
das ist erkenne ich mich gar nicht aus
aber als der impfung interesse da gibt
es da gibt's martina so ein bild von
babys die werden glaube ich so berühmt
dass die in so ein behälter gesteckt
werden weil sonst ganz gern sich still
halten
genau das behaupten die gegner immer die
werden dann geschreddert wenn es ums
movie maker oder so und zeigen auch
immer dieses bild von dem baby das
kindheit so letztendlich ohne stecken
torex die arme und die schulterblätter
auch nach außen rotiert sein müssen und
die kinder still halten müssen und das
sieht vielleicht bisschen martialisch
aus aber hier ist ein jahr gar nicht so
produktion von atrium
und die werden geschreddert aber deshalb
sind wir genau bei den punkt das ist
meine erfahrung so ein bisschen
gerade in den letzten jahren oder in den
letzten jahrzehnten seit dem es internet
gibt wir sagen ja immer hey leute seid
mündige verbraucher informiert euch
damit ihr auch mit den experten mit dem
arzt zum beispiel mit dem verkäufer
diskutieren könnt und für und wider von
einem gerät oder eben der therapie
sprechen könnte ja und dann informieren
sich die leute im internet und für mich
ist das ein bisschen auch ursache oder
der hintergrund historischer das
internet html diese sprache das ist für
wissenschaft erschaffen worden
am anfang war das internet bestand nur
aus wissenschaftlichen doppel
wissenschaftlerin war ganz froh dass sie
in dokument stadt in der quellenangabe
die man danach lesen musste einfach nur
einen pfifferling packen konnten und da
kommt man drauf klicken und wurde dann
zur nächsten studio gelandet aus der
zitiert wurde
das war ein riesenfortschritt und ich
glaube so ein bisschen kommt der
irrglaube daher alles was im internet
ist das ist wahr und sprich es gibt ja
youtube videos die von uns fünf und zum
beispiel das war das ja ich sag mal so
da werde man darf er nicht da ist ist ja
nicht in anführungszeichen war es ist
belegt und ich sag mal die
relativitätstheorie von albert einstein
diese zwischen hunderte male belegt das
heißt sie ist sie gilt und trotzdem geht
natürlich immer noch newtons gesetz
allerdings wir wissen dass auch minuten
das gravitation dass der apfel vom baum
immer und auf die erde fällt daher
übrigens auch der name von apple hat
sowas mit hier ich habe eine idee zu tun
dass gravitation eben ein phänomen ist
der relativitätstheorie und damit zu den
juden zu setzen führt allerdings eben es
ist relativität und ihn umso höher die
gravitation wird und so schneller man
sich fortbewegt umso mehr
ändern sich dann auch die gesetze und
dann wird sogar ich sag mal in
anführungszeichen ein bisschen spucke
wir wollen aber auch über einzelne ganz
wunderbare also da war ich noch ein
entschuldigung wollte ich mal sagen
informationen dann denken sie youtube
videos werden schon ein beweis und
selbst wenn die haben teilweise so
aufwendige grafische vorstände und dann
reden sie mit seiner kennen jetzt in
stimme und dann denk mal okay der redet
ja als hätte ahnung und dann hat auch
noch einen tollen grafischen vorspann
und die musik ist auch ganz toll kann
man sich alles für ganz kleines geld auf
entsprechenden portalen besorgen und
schon den die leute man nur eine beta
das noch landen zum teil in die
verlinkten quellen kommt da genau das
heraus dem wir wollten uns in unserer
lieblings theorie den flachen die
absolut ja das ist ja der beste
verschwörungstheorie die es gibt
sozusagen weil die einerseits so
bekloppt ist aber dann doch eine relativ
große anhängerschaft hat überraschend
beweise also wird es auch ein paar
tausend leute in deutschland gestellt
sind usa ist wichtig groß es gibt auch
amerikanische kanäle die sich bewerben
möchte die sehr professionell die kugel
gestalt der erde meinen zu widerlegen
was sie natürlich in der realität nicht
tun haben wir auch nicht bewusst ist ein
paar monaten erst ein video über xavier
naidoo gemacht habe der behauptet hatte
er das flach und irgendwie ungewöhnlich
oder ironische ab mögliches hat ist
nicht mehr gesagt von wegen aliens leben
in bogen und der welt
doch genau das war der fall es ist das
erfolgreichste video auf seinem kanal
aber nur weil unter dem video der
kommentaren zum zum streit entbrannt ist
und da sind wirklich einige sehr
interessante kommentare geschrieben
wurden
was wirklich einmal einblenden können
genau jetzt kommt er da ist diesmal vor
so erzählt von sonne mond und
schwerkraft warst du schon mal auf dem
mond warst du schon mal oben
lamers mündiger ob die erde flache dar
und ist das macht das den unterschied
keiner denkt einfach mal selber sade adu
kommt aus der bankenstadt frankfurt da
hat er bestimmt mehr infos als julian
draxler auf naja ich sagte später der
satz werden wir alle erfahren was
richtig kam dass der kommentator schon
sehr gut aus was an
verschwörungstheorien so geklappt ist
weil erstens gut die rechtschreibung ist
die eine seite ist auf den diesmal und
da ist alles falsch
das fängt schon damit an dass entweder
du kommt dann noch nicht mal frankfurt
der kommt aus mannheim oder service hin
und habe man wenn man in frankfurt
wohnen spezialwissen
befragt wurden weiß man dass diese stadt
ist wenn man nicht gewohnt oder so ich
komme ich aus frankfurt aber ich glaube
da weiß man es auch nicht besser
aber das ist einfach das start stopp
stoppte kommst du aus dem flachland kiel
wissen dass eben flach ist
ich guck ab und zu auf die ostsee und ja
die erde hört er tatsächlich am horizont
irgendwie auf hast du schon mal einen
hängt das zusammen was wir schon mal
einen stift in der ostsee am horizont
verschwinden sehen das wäre jetzt und es
ist amtlich schon vermutlich schon dass
mir zurückgekommen da raus das heißt es
ist unser gefühl wirklich runter
gefallen das ist halt das beweisen
wollte dann so ein experiment gemacht
hat und dann mit dem experiment bewiesen
hat dass eigentlich die erde rund ist
ironischerweise das wirklich in halle
weise das ist
so und das ist auch ganz bezeichnete
viele leute sagen warum habe ich jetzt
auch nicht schön chat gelesen warum
widmet ihr euch überhaupt diese
verschwörungstheoretikern das beweisen
dass die erde flach ist hat eine rakete
selber gebaut
er hätte sich auch einfach ins flugzeug
setzen können ist egal ist mit dieser
rakete hochgeflogen durch die g kräfte
ist er bewusstlos geworden ist
abgestürzt ist gestorben also ist fast
zu machen wird sie so drauf weil er an
dieser verschwörungstheorie kloten ja
oder es gibt ja ganz viele beispiele
corona usa die republikaner wähler
glauben nicht daran die an keine masken
und die sterben jetzt mal muss man
wirklich sagen es ist mehr auch zum
lachen wenn sie sich so traurig wäre
da sterben die wähler von donald trump
wirklich wie die fliegen weg und ja das
ist wirklich schlimm oder klimawandel
die klimaleugner ich meine der
klimawandel ist es gibt der studie zu
den studien klimawandel und das ist
wissenschaft und viele leute glauben
wenn sie wissenschaft ich sah mich an so
flach ist la comtesse würdest du gerne
mal mäuschen spielen wobei man die
meisten wahrscheinlich auch genauso wie
youtube verfolgen kann
also ich hab mich auch mal gedacht ob
das nicht witzig wer mal auch hier zum
beispiel auf seine corinna demonstration
zu gehen und einfach ein paar leute zu
konfrontieren
wobei ich tatsächlich da manchmal
überlege wie ihr wie sicher das ist dann
alleine oder zu zweit zu dritt gegenüber
einer masse von ein paar hundert leuten
auf so einem kanal
es bringt nix ich war auch da wo war ich
genau hier nach der großen drei des
future demo hier in berlin
da war ich auch unterwegs zusammen wird
man da andere schrien es gab schon x-mal
kleber waren wir auf der erde und sonst
ganz normales dann ruft halb zurück ja
aber die glauben halt und dass das ist
der punkt sie versuchen mit ihrem
verhalten mit ihrer eben wenn jemand in
frankfurt wohnt da muss er ahnung haben
mit irgendwelchen komischen beweisen zu
belegen dass das was sie sagen stimmt
aber es hält halt nicht aus um genau
dieses experiment der flach er traf
haben sie hätten halt ein lichtstrahl
der ja zwangsläufig gerade verläuft
da haben sie hat die kummer mit
nachgewiesen der erde und punkt und
gratis titel sieht weil es gar nicht
welcher sehe dass da ist da sieht man
eben auch die schiffe am horizont
verschwinden
das hat er ja das ist ja das tolle
wissenschaft ist ja zum teil ganz
einfach man kann auch ganz einfach
nachweisen dass co2 und klimagas ist man
tot verschiedene gläser mit
verschiedenen gasen füllen und hat co2
wird wärmer als sauerstoff ist und damit
hat man selber schon bewiesen okay ein
höherer co2 anteil auch in kleinen
mengen wird natürlich die temperatur der
atmosphäre erhöhen und so weiter und so
weiter das ist ja das ist ja super sache
dass sie dann soll wissenschaft anwenden
und ja behaupten sie wären
wissenschaftlich ich habe mich die
letzten monate ich drei gerne bei
youtube hat wahrscheinlich bei
bewusstsein verloren
die flache erst dann glauben auch
eigentlich alle daran das mondlicht
kühlt was auch nicht so ne neben theorie
denn und die flache er glaubt dass auch
das mondlicht kühlt und dann stellen sie
sich mit einem thermometer ans fenster
und stellt dann fest
die temperatur sinkt wenn der mond
aufscheint ich weiß nicht was ja
letztlich dann auch nur belegen soll
mond nicht kühl weil der mond wird gar
nicht von der sonne angestrahlt wie er
böse mainstream behauptet sondern er hat
sein eigenes licht oder ist gar nur eine
ein hologramm oder so das wird ja auch
behauptet dem mond gibt es gar nicht und
so und so gut dass da versucht mit such
soll die wissenschaft zu beweisen weiß
ich was ja zum thema dass das wirklich
gefährlich werden kann sehen wir jetzt
ja gerade an den anti corona demus aus
der auch schon gesagt dass martin mit
attila hildmann der wirklich vor dem
reichstag demonstrieren aggressiv wird
leute angepöbelt und ich glaube da sieht
man dass sich das radikalisierten und
eine ganz gefährliche richtung
ja und bei dem chor ohne ding ist er
jetzt auch so während die flachter
vielleicht für sich selbst gefährlich
sind stellen diese leute in der mehrzahl
zum beispiel natürlich dann irgendwie
großen großveranstaltungen keine masken
zusammentragen und natürlich für sich
und andere einfach eine gefährdung da er
also
für sich vielleicht gar nicht mal so
wenn sie jetzt nicht zur risikogruppe
gehören ja aber auch für ihre
mitmenschen auf jeden fall
und ja das ist natürlich nicht gut und
schafft ein großer gläubiger auch an
verschwörungstheorien bdf gegnerschaft
oder eben an corona die tragen lang
keine masken und ich meine da die
unterschreiben die erklärung dass sie
das risiko eingehen und donald trump
nicht dafür haftbar machen aber sie
stecken ja andere leute an ich meine wo
hört dass die gucken noch nicht mehr
über tellerrand also das ist wirklich
ganz dramatisch ja auch letztendlich
diese diese denke dass das masken tragen
irgendwie für den eigenschutz da ist das
ist primär für fremdschutz da und ich
möchte auch noch mal zum thema scheint
daran erinnern an die grünen an die
grandiosen ideen desinfektionsmittel iv
zu geben oder oder irgendwie das uv
licht in den körper zu kriegen ja da
gibt es auch ganz witzige animationen
team an das über welche körperöffnungen
der körper kriegen aber da muss man
einfach sich auch das gesicht der ärztin
anschauen die einfach da rechts neben
ihm sitzen sich ja wirklich anstrengen
muss und sich zu kontrollieren
also ja das ist wirklich stimmt doch was
ist deine lieblings verschwörungstheorie
die theorie mit der ich mich am liebsten
auseinandersetze ist auf jeden fall die
klimawandel leugnen weil man ja eben
wenn man dann versucht sich mit den
ganzen theorien auseinanderzusetzen das
thema auch am ende besser versteht wenn
man sich den magen genug damit
auseinandersetzt also und das ist auch
so ein kleines problem das man würde ich
sagen wenn man wirklich daran glaubt
dass der klimawandel nicht von den von
den menschen machten von den menschen
gemacht ist also anthropogenen ist das
ist ja dass man sozusagen vielleicht
sich einfach ein bisschen
bisschen auch an experten halten sollte
und vielleicht nicht einfach sagen
sollte ich bin jetzt der experte wenn
ich mir zwei artikeln im internet
durchlese es ist ein thema das seit 200
jahren diskutiert wird ungefähr
es ist ein thema wo sich tausende
wissenschaftler zusammentreffen darüber
diskutieren und sie kommen ihnen zu
ergebnissen und diese ergebnisse werden
dann eben teilweise ja versucht zu
widerlegen nachdem man sich ein youtube
video angeguckt hat und ja das ist schon
verrückt und deshalb setze ich mich
damit doch schon sehr gerne auseinander
dann auch mit den leuten zu diskutieren
und selber so auch mehr darüber zu
erfahren weil dann kommt man natürlich
nach ja was ist da dran was sie sagen
was es da nicht dran
gibt es vielleicht andere hinweise
darauf und ja also das ist ja so ein
punkt
ich weiß gar nicht mehr von euch gesagt
es gibt ja auch durchaus
verschwörungstheorien weserpark männchen
wahrheit drin sind beim klimawandel
würde ich jetzt habe ich das noch nicht
erlebt aber keine ahnung sind ältere
autos umweltschädlicher als benziner
das ist ein so multidimensionales thema
und natürlich wird viel energie für die
batterien aufgewendet die halten aber
inzwischen sehr lang und so weiter und
so fort
ich sag mal sehr geschickte
verschwörungstheorien die nehmen auch
die somebody kombinieren stimmende
fakten mit fantasie und da dann wird da
eine vermeintliche theorie daraus ich
muss mal kurz in den chat gehen also
erstens doctor strange der mensch mit
den vielen zahlen und buchstaben in
seinem namen hat inzwischen 70 euro
gespendet
heute ist der absolute wahnsinn das habe
ich noch nie so erlebt also erstmal
vielen vielen dank für die unterstützung
unserer arbeit
das stecken wir natürlich alles und das
muss man wirklich sagen wir stecken hier
wirklich jeden cent in unsere videos und
alles was wir nur können weil naja es
ist nicht so dass man
zumindest in der deutschen deutschen
sprachraum mit youtube großreich werden
kann
vornehmlich in der wissenschaft ich
glaube wir alle haben eine leidenschaft
dafür und ich muss ehrlich sagen
verschwörungstheorien sind mit für mich
ein grund für meine leidenschaft für
wissenschaft um immer mehr menschen
davon zu überzeugen wie eben
wissenschaft im gegensatz zu ihm wissen
ja also es ist wirklich hier ist seit
einem jahr drei monaten und 27 tagen
unserer unterstützer also ganz ganz
großen dank
wir müssen unbedingt eben und dafür sind
wir da und das machen wir gerne etwas
gegen verschwörungstheorien tun und ich
habe übrigens angeregt und das hat jetzt
ich würde mal sagen wirklich unabhängig
von mir schon zu den ersten konsequenzen
geführt in amerika sind ja einige kanäle
aber auch vor einigen wegen ihres hasses
wegen des sabbats bedingung acht
wirklich fakten vermittelt werden muss
dass was nicht stimmt was gelogen at und
was an den haaren herbeigezogen ist dass
das auch weil es keine meinung dass es
geht nicht um meinungsfreiheit sondern
es geht darum ich weiß gar nicht ob ich
noch zu hören wenn ich muss mal wieder
aber gott darum geht dass hier menschen
wirklich manipuliert wer durch wirklich
komplett alte fakten
ich weiß gar nicht dieses oberbayern hat
alternative fakten
es gibt sie nicht es gibt nur fakten wir
wissen zum teil nicht was sie fakten
sind dafür gibt es forschung dafür
gibt's wissenschaft um fakten heraus zu
bekommen und nicht fakten zu erfinden
und ich bin dafür dass man wenn man
darauf gefragt wird nachweisen können
sollte dass man fakten verbreitet und
nicht dass man eben irgendwelche
fantasiegebilde verbreitet weil wie
gefährlich das ist das sieht man an
trump und twitter hat ja schon reagiert
twitter hat falsche aussagen und
der artikel darunter klingt aber das bin
ich glaube es muss geben dass auf den
auch und die zu diesen beiden
verschwörungstheorien bei wenn man dann
mal eine sekunde auf passau
es gibt ein wo nämlich ich habe pia
lamberti ja gefragt und so gesagt wie
viele leute dann verschwimmt wie das in
der krise ist es gut
und wenn du diesen o-ton gerd kanter ist
erst der vince versucht den weg zu
wählen wenn es versucht hat den lecks zu
beheben
wenn man gleich mit gehören so jetzt
baustopp fordert zu anscheinend mit den
zahlreichen quellen
ja das ist ja dass ist ein bisschen
schade ja die frage ist halt baut kommt
in der krise ist es ja so viel jetzt
hoch letztlich auch in meinem einer
story erwähnt robbie williams ist jetzt
auch zu die verschwörungstheorie die
dann über glaubten
da geht ein ring der sich irgendein ein
paar einer pizzeria trifft der kinder zu
bekommen
ich glaube auch umbringen die pizzeria
hat noch gar kein keller
wir wollen das mit dem mit dem pizza
geld was ganz auf unsere sowie behörde
dass ich mal was mit dem pizza geld ist
so die krönung der verschwörungstheorie
war das wirklich alles top da geht es ja
darum dass kinder unterirdisch gefangen
gehalten werden aber einige millionen
und alle prominenten der welt
das irgendwie unterstützen und dann gibt
es aber auch angebliche
befreiungsaktionen dieser kinder
die werden da den usa verbracht aber
noch mal einen dieser leute fragt wo
sind denn die kinder über einige
millionen kinder
sie befreit werden wo sind sie und das
scheint mir doch so eine art eskapismus
zu sein dass wir uns gefragt warum in
krisenzeiten die leute besonders stark
an sowas glauben dass da wohl weil sie
überfordert mit der realität sind und
dann versuchen die kontrolle zurück zu
erlangen und sagen ich weiß es besser
als der rest und dadurch
erhält man eben wieder irgendwie die
kontrolle über das eigene spiel
yahoo war in roland garros saß die in
solchen krisenzeiten natürlich leute
angst haben existenzen auch bedroht sind
usw
dementsprechend vielleicht diese leute
deshalb besonders verwundbar sind eben
gegenüber solcher theorien also ich lese
wie wird er natürlich auch nicht
einfachen antworten
in solchen zeiten weil es ist natürlich
eine informationsflut die auf ihn
einprasselt ich meine die top
wissenschaftler oder
wissenschaftlerinnen der welt sind da
dran alle studien überblick zu behalten
und die studien zusammenzufassen für
sich und ja wie soll es dann für den
laien möglich sein ist alles so schnell
zu verstehen ist es eben nicht deshalb
sucht man nach möglichst einfachen
antworten
und die gibt es meistens schon
irgendwelchen verschwörungs mythen auf
youtube denn die wissenschaft wie
christoph waltz schon gesagt hat es ist
ein prozess
sie wird nicht sofort am ersten tag alle
antworten liefern die
verschwörungstheoretiker tun das
meistens die wissen meistens auch schon
wie es aufhört und ja welcher plan
dahinter steckt der interessen
halbfinalisten mit dem hintern ist also
ein zweischneidiges schwert
auf der einen seite habe er völlig recht
erst durch das internet kann sich so was
so krass verbreiten
früher haben wir die leute
wahrscheinlich auch schon oder die haben
ihren quatsch eben postboten oder so
oder in den köpfen gemacht heute ganze
stadt überall verbreiten
andererseits bietet das internet
natürlich auch das erste mal der
menschheitsgeschichte zugang zur
kompletten bildung für alle
also ich tendiere dazu zu sagen die
vorteile überwiegen die nachteile da ist
viel könnte ja durch das internet eben
auch wissen verbreiten
die frage ist nur wie wie steuert man
das wie verhindert man die
fehlinformation und das ist gar nicht so
einfach würde ich sagen und vereinsleben
bei manchen sachen ist ja auch nicht
klar was ist falsch
ich meine es gibt sachen wie klimawandel
die form der erde da gibt es halt nur
richtig oder falsch aber waren ja sagten
ja durchaus diskussion möglich sein
da wird es schwierig deswegen sondern
geht es manchmal um wahrscheinlichkeiten
und so weiter und einfach wie man dass
man gewisse sachen kontext setzt und das
verstehen hat wieder nicht
ja da ist auch eine frage also erstmal
noch mal wieder in den chat auch
auf disc ort so bin ich zu hören
eigentlich erst war bei 87 m springen
war total
es gibt eine frage aus dem chat und zwar
aber meistens von disk ort genau sind
verschwörungstheorien allgemein nicht
nur in bestimmten zeiten auf mangelhafte
bildung zurückzuführen
und ja was ist da euer eindruck wenn man
wissenschaftlich irgendwie sich mit
wissenschafts geschäftig kann man dann
an verschwörungstheorien glauben also
bei wissenschaftlern gesagt ja ich
verstehe manchmal nicht warum manche
leute nicht an wissenschaftler glauben
beziehungsweise der vertrauen weil ich
habe mich an ein kommentar erinnern der
mir jetzt ein feld der kamen unter dem
video von ja über regierung flairs dass
das heißt es ging darin um satelliten
und dann kam nur ein kommentar es gibt
keine satelliten und dann habe ich mir
gedacht okay das schreibt das schreibst
du hier gerade in deinen händen nie rein
und benutzt in dem moment ja super
ärgerlich unterscheiden sondern mit dem
sie von uns vielleicht eine anleitung
bekommen
ja es ist genauer zu verstehen und auch
zwischen den farbtönen zu unterscheiden
wie gesagt nicht nur schwarz und weiß
ich wieder braucht jetzt tut sich wieder
was ja wir sind dort nein so ja liebe
leute wir haben gerade darüber
diskutiert und biete das kommt auch aus
dem chat jetzt höre ich mich nur doppelt
leider so das habe ich jetzt weg und
zwar die frage war warum unterhalten
sich jetzt wissenschaftler die an corona
glauben und die nicht an krone glauben
warum unterhalten sich warum es und
setzte sich auseinander und ich habe
dann erst mal gesagt wieso es gibt doch
keine wissenschaftler die nicht daran
glauben also glauben ist hier auch das
falsche wort die ich sag mal die these
vertreten und das immer direkt schon bei
dem unterschied zwischen verschwörung
theorien und keine verschwörungstheorien
es geht hier nicht um glauben sondern es
gibt wissenschaftler tatsächlich
wahrscheinlich auch wissenschaftlerinnen
die gegenthese narben zu bewohner die
zum beispiel sagen das ist gar nicht so
anstecken oder die wibag ein ehemaliger
lungenarzt denn lieber praktiziert der
sagt ja das war alles ein irrtum in
italien
wenn die länder das und das gemacht
worden ist dann wäre das nicht passiert
und so weiter warum unterhalten sie sich
nicht und tom du hattest da ein ganz
wichtiges buch gesagt wir sollten das
nicht einfach nur so von der hand weisen
was ist was ist rein wie wird wie soll
man also was angehen ja die die kritik
kam jetzt auch aus dem chat dass man
natürlich nicht einfach sagen sollte das
ist quatsch soll dann lässt man sich ja
eigentlich auf das niveau herab wie die
leute die sagen dass die etablierten
wissenschaftler nur quatsch erzählen
martin was sagst du dazu naja es ist
schwer zu sagen es gibt sachen die sind
nur quatsch ja und da muss man auch
ehrlicherweise sagen wenn mir jemand
ihren kommentaren
zwei youtube videos auf 50 minuten
schickt mit irgendwelchen gruppe sachen
dann werde ich die nicht anschauen weil
meine zeit besser genutzt ist und
ähnliches gilt glaube ich auch teilweise
für die wissenschaftler die auch andere
sachen zu tun haben und man muss
natürlich sagen es gibt von anderen
wissenschaftlern schon andere thesen
bezüglich nutzen bestimmter maßnahmen
bestimmte infektiosität sachen usw
und das ist ja auch was anderes als
leute die komplett nicht an sozusagen
das corona wir uns an sich glauben was
er ganz klar ließen es gibt und das aber
dann tatsächlich sehr kompliziert weil
er oft auch wahre kern vielleicht
drinnen ist aber das schwierigste ist
natürlich bei den leuten dann
herauszufinden inwieweit die wirklich
noch wissenschaftlich tätig sind oder
eben am beispiel wo dax auch schon seit
längerer zeit bezug zu verschiedenen
anderen verschwörungstheorien und so
weiter haben
es gibt ja eben auch unter den entgegen
ein paar schwarze schafe also unter den
ersten paar schwarze schafe die
endgegner sind und sich damit meistens
auch eine goldene nase verdienen
eigentlich sind diese leute besonders
schwierig oder schwimmen die dem ganzen
noch mal einen seriösen anstrich gehen
weiter also gibt es da einen fließenden
übergang von ihsan wissenschaft zu
verschwörungstheorien oder gibt es da
eine klare linie tatsächlich für mich
schwierig zu sagen
also es kommt immer darauf an also bei
mancher argumenten ganz klar ja solche
sachen wie bezüglich bestimmter aussagen
zum beispiel zu den masten
grundsätzliche aussagen zum corona virus
was ganz klar verschwörung ist also
solche sachen die es versteht krone
virus gibt es gar nicht und so walter ja
das ist überhaupt nicht schlimm
solche sachen auf der anderen seite
wieder gibt eben schon in fließenden
übergänge oder auch eben
wissenschaftliche sachen wenn es eben
glaube ich von einer anderen
wissenschaftler gibt es eine gewisse
diskussion wie jetzt bestimmte zum
beispiel kitas oder schulschließungen
oder uni schließung wie viel das jetzt
wirklich bringt was man einführen sollte
bz welche lockerungen man machen sollte
und das ist dann die da was anderes da
kann man diskutieren weit ist auch
ehrlicherweise dazu natürlich relativ
wenig daten gibt weil wir so eine
situation weltweit eigentlich noch nie
hatten in dem ausmaß unserer heutigen
zeit muss das wahrscheinlich eine
wissenschaftliche und politische ebene
drin müssen wir die wissenschaft ist ein
fakten leute das ganz klar
verschwörungstheoretiker das gesagt es
gibt kein cola virus der hat auch keine
meinung in dem sie lesen der falsche
fakten aber wer sagt er es gibt tee cola
virus aber ich möchte andere maßnahmen
als ihr ich möchte keinen doktor aus den
und dem kunden das ist seine meinung
derer zustimmt oder nicht
das wäre dann die politik das muss man
schon getrennt und ja und die man dann
natürlich wissenschaftlich diskutieren
kann und auch theoretisch widerlegen
kann ja also ich meine sowas kenne dann
natürlich noch immer falsch oder richtig
sein aber das ist natürlich etwas
worüber man reden wobei man diskutieren
kann weiß dass solche sachen wie der
korona virus gibbs gar nicht genau wie
es gibt schon seit 60 jahren ja die
familie der korona viren ist seit 60
jahren entdeckt aber das sah skoda virus
2 also dass wir das womit wir uns jetzt
die letzten monate lang beschäftigen das
gibt es nicht seit 60 jahren
und solche auch einfach verständnis
unterschiede bodack ist dass das ist ja
eigentlich ein wissenschaftler der war
der ist meines wissens nach kein
wissenschaftler sondern war eine
lungenfacharzt also ein praktizierender
arzt ja ich kenne mich aber nicht extrem
gut tatsächlich mit ihm aus dass das
möglichst im bundesrat muss es einen
grenzwert ist das den
verschwörungstheorien oder was ist das
wenn mediziner der eigentlich ahnung von
dem thema hat eine so andere these
vertritt und sogar sagt das was wir in
italien sehen hat nichts mit dem virus
zu tun sondern das ist ein falsches
management
da gibt es ein problem denke ich da gibt
es ein problem und zwar was ist ein
expert also es gibt jetzt ein junger
arzt aber ist nun arzt ein virologe nein
ist er nicht wenn wenn christian drosten
im podcast schon sagt er befasst sich
ungefähr seit 20 jahren etwas weniger
als 20 jahren mit corona viren und er
traut sich gerade so in der
öffentlichkeit darüber zu sprechen und
würde sich nicht trauen über andere
viren zu reden ja dann muss man sich
schon fragen damit sind sollte sich
fragen ob denn jeder mensch der einen
abschluss hat gleich ein experte in
irgendein thema ist es wird nicht jeder
chemiker auf der welt ein experte in
sachen klimawandel sein
es wird nicht jeder physiker auf der
welt ein experte zur mondlandung sein so
funktioniert es nicht die wissenschaft
besteht also die moderne wissenschaft
wie wir sie kennen besteht jetzt seit
gerade mal ja ein paar jahrzehnten
beziehungsweise ein paar hundert jahren
und es wurde einfach so viel entdeckt
und es haben sich so viele unserer
gebiete der wissenschaften etabliert
dass es überhaupt nicht mehr möglich ist
für jemanden der einfach nur ein
bestimmtes fach studiert hat über alles
eine übersicht zu haben und in allem ein
experte zu sein deshalb alleine weil man
einen jungen arzt ist ist man noch kein
experte für corona beer
also ja er kennt sich mit vielem aus ja
und ja moment aber also harald lesch ich
mag ihn übrigens er
er hat natürlich auch vorher
wissenschaftliches format und auf dieser
populärwissenschaftlichen ebene kannst
du dich natürlich als professor an der
lmu münchen über die meisten sachen
unterhalten und er kennt sich mit
sicherheit auch richtig gut in sehr
vielen themen aus aber auch harald lesch
würde nicht von sich behaupten wenn man
jetzt wirklich in die aller tiefsten
details jeder themengebiete geht dass er
auf jedem experte ist sowas würde harald
lesch nicht machen weil er meiner
meinung nach ja selbst reflektiert genug
dafür ist sowas würde er nicht behaupten
er ist es aber ja und auf dem gebiet
kennt er sich wirklich gut aus ich bin
boes auf das thema gekommen weil weil
ich mal irgendwann hat er sich mal
geäußert in dem video zu corona also
nicht in einem seiner eigenen videos
sondern da war zu gast bei irgendeinem
einer talkshow oder sowas
und dann habe ich die kommentare ein
bisschen durchgelesen und dann stand da
von einigen halt auch ist jetzt ein
astrophysiker auch noch corona experten
muss ich dem das glauben sollte dem sinn
ich finde er hat eine starke kompetenz
und er hat sich ganz sicher mit dem
thema beschäftigt war jemand der so klug
ist klug ist wie er der wird sich nicht
einfach da hinstellen und irgendwas
sagen also der hat sich bestimmt vorher
damit beschäftigen das ist doch mal eine
klare grenzen ziehen
es gibt experten wirklich experten wie
christian drosten zum beispiel der sich
wirklich also sehr umfassend mit einem
thema beschäftigt hat und wirklich
bescheid weißt aber es gibt doch eine
andere personengruppe in diesem ganzen
informations geschäft nenne ich mal und
das sind und journalisten wie wir auch
wie er arbeitete als journalistin und
wir sind keine experten das wird dann
komme ich gleich noch einmal ein kleines
detail erzählen wir sind keine experten
aber wir wissen
wie wir unsere wie wir quellen zitieren
können die wir quellen zusammenfassen
können wird beziehen und zb auf einen
christian drosten oder wir werden bei zb
einem anderen virologen kekulé der kaum
was veröffentlicht hat im nächsten jahr
werden wir auch eher skeptisch berichten
also wir erstens neben quellen zweiter
wir sortieren sie ein wir beurteilen die
quellen nach ihrem wert und das ist
relativ einfach die leute die greifen
immer irgendwas aus dem internet und
weinen dann falls da ist dann ist es da
nein es gibt kriterien mit denen man
quellen und auch experten bewerten kann
und da habe ich war eine interessante
diskussion mit peter frey chefredakteur
vom zdf weil da taucht da muss man echt
aufpassen im heute-journal tauchen
relativ häufig leute aus dem zdf aus und
da steht dann so zu terrorismus experte
da ist es wirklich schwierig ich habe
auch gesagt dass ich finde das kann man
nicht machen das ist ein journalist der
hat sich eingearbeitet in ein thema aber
er kann ich kein experte sagen wir da
nicht dazu geforscht hat er hat sich
schlau gemacht dazu und er kann als
jemand der sich über das thema
informiert hat informationen weitergeben
aber eigentlich ist er selbst nicht der
experte weil er herrgott nochmal aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht einfach keine
ahnung hat und da muss man dann auch
ehrlich sagen das ist ein bisschen
schwierig bei den medien dass sie solche
leute als expertin darstellen unabhängig
davon dass natürlich diese medien heute
tagesschau tagesspiegel der spiegel die
zeit und so weiter also gute mainstream
medien natürlich wirklich wie wir auch
journalistisch sauber arbeiten das schon
sagen aber ich sag mal das ist so die
bandbreite an expertentum und recherche
und informationen und in diesem rahmen
kann natürlich auch ein
harald lesch über das berichten was er
zusammengetragen hat weil er hat sich
als über das thema informiert aber er
ist dann halt nicht der experte zum
thema corona sondern ein kollege der
sich zu dem thema schlaugemacht hat und
ich finde das kann man akzeptieren dass
es aber auch drei
friend gemacht werden weil er und ich
auf die diskussion und es habe natürlich
auch so dass er den größten den höchsten
akademischen grad inne hat eben den grad
eines professors das heißt er weiß ganz
genau weiß es besser als der
durchschnittliche journalist natürlich
wie man eben wissenschaftliche themen
recherchiert er hat genug paper in
seinem leben gelesen dass er im relativ
schnell wissenschaftliche dokumente
durchgehen kann und ist natürlich auch
viel schneller aufnehmen kann
es heißt ja sozusagen das
grundverständnis ist natürlich viel
höher was wissenschaftliche methoden
angeht
aber trotzdem muss man halt insgesamt
sollen das ist also ich mache halt total
der weiß natürlich auch super viel aber
bei seiner sendung öffentlich
rechtlichen ist er hat mittlerweile so
ein bisschen fast zum erklärt europa
degradiert und das finde ich halt mir
hat mal da hin dass sie jegliches gipfel
vorgelegt werden zu ganz anderen themen
als ausdruck der sich auch unten
da denken dann vielleicht manche leute
das kann doch nicht alles wissen und das
weißt ja auch nicht alles kann er auch
es gibt eine berühmte doku über
elektroautos und die gewinnung von
lithium da ideen an so ein zweites und
das ist so aber ich sag mal so das
passiert heißt auch das muss man auch
sagen natürlich machen medien fehler dpa
natürlich auch und spiegel alle machen
auch fehler das ist ganz normal niemand
kann immer absolut korrekt sein
nur das ist der große unterschied zu rtl
klar
die geschichte aus dem spiegel wo
windkrafträder schlecht gemacht wurden
der wahrheit sauber recherchiert aber
rhetorisch dann eine hat er die
windräder schlecht machen wollen weil er
aus der damalige chefredakteur keine vor
seinem haus gebaut haben wollte das
sieht man diesen artikeln dann aber auch
an also ein bisschen mit ein bisschen
gespür ich kann nur ein kleiner tipp
geben wenn er ständig scheinbar offenbar
es erweckt den anschein
es ist nicht von der hand zu weisen und
so weiter wenn all diese formulierung
auftauchen ist so ein bisschen wie in
der immobilie beschreibung dann weiß man
stimmt nämlich oder wer kann man dran
fühlen oder da kann man dran fällen das
mal in köln sagt ja also fehler
passieren natürlich kennen wir auch also
mir ist ja auch schon mal ein paar
videos sondern er festgestellt habe oder
schnitte nicht aber dann versucht man
das eben zu korrigieren sondern bekommen
dass ich noch mal so ein paar spezis und
sagen hier hast du was falsches erzählt
nur das lässt sich eben nicht vermeiden
und wenn man das korrigiert ist das ja
auch gerade ein zeichen für wissenschaft
ist ein bisschen das was du einfach mal
dass christoph wissenschaft versucht ja
gar nicht immer im recht zu sein sondern
lässt sich vielleicht auch gerne
korrigieren
wohingegen verschwörungstheoretiker eben
selbst wenn sie werden ihre theorien
quasi falsifiziert werden immer noch
daran festhalten und sich eben gar nicht
überzeugen lassen das ist auch so ein
bisschen
jetzt möchte ich das thema religion auch
machen muss hat was religiöses wenn man
sagt das ist eben dass diese meinung
steht für mich fest und die suche jetzt
nach dem beweisen hervor
statt zu sagen ich suche erst über weise
und mit mir dann meine meinung sagen
möchte ich ja und man muss halt immer
dass er das spannende
ich sag mal dunkle materie da ist ein
ständiger widerstreit der wissenschaft
wird ständig gibt es argumente dafür
dagegen das könnte es sein dass nicht es
gibt das gleiche wahnsinn das finde ich
einfach super stand übrigens an dieser
stelle soll mit vielen dank an stefan
kooths
ja zum beispiel ist ein ganz wichtiges
beispiel ein verschwörungstheoretiker
auch teilweise zu recht sagen man darf
nicht alles glauben was einem gesagt
wird dass für sich stimmt ja zum
beispiel damals ganz berühmt als nach
dem weltkrieg ddr entstanden ist gab es
die verschwörungstheorie niemand hat die
absicht eine mauer zu bauen und die
leute die das in zweifel gezogen haben
die waren ziemlich gut beraten würde ich
mal sagen also das zeigt dass man nicht
zwingend alles glauben sollte was ein
barzelt wird oder was den leuten dort
korea jeden tag erzählt wird von der
regierung das sind was alles falsch
das heißt man darf auch nicht blind
alles glauben das möchte ich den
verschwörungstheoretikern doch
eingestehen dass sie war recht haben nur
dann schießen sie natürlich immer völlig
kostenlos
also zu dem dritten gebäude das muss man
eigentlich gar nicht heranziehen wenn
man wenn man die geschichte mal revue
passieren lassen will weil weil allein
die beiden tower die haupt tower wie die
zusammen geschützt sind allein das wenn
es dann ans physikalisch unmögliche geht
dann dann kann man langsam darüber
nachdenken ob vielleicht nicht doch
diese verschwörungstheorie auch zum teil
also man da gibt es ja die gehen ja bis
in die tiefen wo es dann übertrieben
wird aber zum teil könnte die schon da
könnte was dran sein weil ja
physikalisch also physik kann ja keiner
von uns umgehen und in dem fall ist es
einfach so stellt die hat das gebäude
hat so viele stahlträger drin gehabt wie
kein anderes gebäude vorher und ein
flugzeug ist auch ist aus aluminium und
ja wenn jetzt ein flugzeug in ein
gebäude mit hunderten stahlträgern
einfliegt dann dann kann das nicht sein
dass ein werkstoff der sehr viel weniger
festigkeit wie stahl
diese stahlträger durchbohrt die butter
also man kann sich das ganz gut
vorstellen einmal wenn man sich
umgekehrt vorstellt dass dass man sagt
man nimmt den wolkenkratzer und
beschleunigt in auf 800 stundenkilometer
oder oder so ähnlich und lässt ihn gegen
ein stehendes flugzeug krachen was
passiert dann wird das flugzeug in
tausend teile zersplittert wird es wie
mit einem baseballschläger weg
weggeschlagen oder versinkt wie butter
im wolkenkratzer und ich glaube also
dass das in den wolkenkratzer eintaucht
das kann man sich in dem fall nicht gut
vorstellen oder wie ich also daran
beteilige ich mich leider überhaupt
nicht also ist schon wirklich auf das
porto nur fürs porto ja was ist
also davon distanzieren mein problem
daran ist nämlich ich hab keine ahnung
sagen wir tatsächlich richtig also
erstmal erstmal habe ich mich zu wenig
damit auseinandergesetzt aber es ist
eben so ja das ist eben physikalisch
nicht widerlegt ist das ist unmöglich
ist dass diese ist diese als ich meine
jetzt nicht ich meine es nicht dass die
die flugzeuge dar ein fliegen sondern
eben judith liegt wie das
zusammengestürzt ist also ja was ist die
hypothese dass die amerikanische
regierung das den gesprengt hat um einen
krieg anzufangen als oder das ist auch
so wir mit der mondbahn oder müssten so
viele leute beteiligt gewesen seien
10.000 und die man auch jahre zum
schweigen gebracht hat es ist da stimme
ich zu
ganz klar aber ich nur eine simple frage
im raum
ich frage mich halt warum und es ist
bisher noch bei keinem gebäude jemals in
der geschichte passiert dass es durch
feuer so zusammengestürzt ist wie das
world trade center
es ist passiert es ist ja eine oberen
oberen viertel sage ich mal ungefähr ist
das flugzeug eingeflogen
und wenn jetzt wirklich die hitze
ausgereicht hat um die stahlträger zu
schmelzen
und da bräuchte man über 1000 grad dann
würde doch der teil der obere teil
einfach abfallen
du hast du sondern das dann auch ganz
andere physikalische kräfte durch den
aufprall
ich möchte mal sagen da bin ich
tatsächlich vollkommen überfragt heraus
ich habe das nine eleven angeht gar
keine ahnung
erschossen worden ist das ist schon
alles ich sag mal extrem seltsam oder
wenn man auch watergate sid ich sag mal
außer jetzt was alles bei jump passiert
dann traut man den usa durchaus einiges
zu aber der punkt beim 1
man hörte ich glaube ich nicht hört man
mich nicht warum man so ja also ganz
starte ich jetzt wieder man hier jetzt
geht's wieder schreiben so und bei nine
eleven gibt es tatsächlich ein
fachgutachten zum zusammensturz des
dritten gebäudes und das ist halt nicht
von irgendwelchen dokumentarfilm an also
ins wenig geht ja gar nicht von der hand
weisen dass es den einen oder andern
aber die journalisten der dann auch mal
der bärtige der irgendwas zusammen gehen
aber da gibt es tatsächlich ein
gutachten das beim dritten gebäude sagt
da sind alle stelzen zum gleichen
zeitpunkt in der gleichen sekunde
zusammengebrochen
was ist natürlich extrem seltsam aber
auch dafür kann es natürlich
wissenschaftliche erklärung geben die
nicht ich sage mal eben eine
verschwörung da steckt den
verschwörungen drin
die große verschwörung von irgendwelchen
dunklen mächten und nicht nur eine
absurde theorie ich sage mal in dem
sinne ist die flache erde eigentlich gar
keine verschwörungstheorie weil es ja
keine verschwörung ist sondern einfach
nur ein anderer fakt die verschwörung
werden die die die runde erde
verschwörungen die irgendwann mal
öffentlich auf gestartet hat aber das
ist ja genau der widerstreit und da
funktioniert wissenschaft halt anders
wenn wir jetzt diese thesen haben zum
beispiel zu nine eleven
dann würden wir gucken welche gutachten
gibt es dazu und gehen wir uns wirklich
zweifel
und ich finde ich sollte man vielleicht
ein video dazu machen ist nine eleven
gibt es eine verschwörungstheorie
und da gibt es da wirkliche zweifel und
gibt es auch wissenschaftliche zweifel
ja das ist wirklich der einzige punkt
moment angreifen kann gibt es
wissenschaftliche 2 wo sich der auch
markus widersprechen von jemand der im
youtube video macht beweist wie es jetzt
wir können alles sagen sondern wohl
stimmt also wirklich eine
wissenschaftliche studie voller instanz
dahinter ist weil das du dir harald
lesch wenn jemand studiert hat kann er
komplett anders mit studien mit
ergebnissen
mit rückschlägen umgehen kombination es
ist auch nicht so dass ich jetzt da
vollkommen überzeugt bin dass nine
eleven wirklich eine verschwörung war es
ist halt eine eine der wenigen
verschwörungstheorien wo man noch
genauer hinschauen könnte also war es
machen wie die mondlandungen gefegt da
muss man finde ich meiner meinung nach
gar nicht genauer hinschauen die ist
passiert oder flache erde noch noch
besser
die erde ist nicht flach dass das ist so
das sind solche themen die einfach fällt
eine festere basis haben aber bei nine
eleven finde ich kann man schon genauer
mal hinschauen es gibt auch eine
wissenschaftliche theorie zu dem
zusammensturz und zwar dass die
flugzeuge
christoph ist er kommt mir doch okay ja
die flugzeuge könnten geschmolzen seien
durch die hohe hitze könnten dadurch
flüssiges zu flüssigem aluminium
geworden sein und es gibt einen effekt
wenn flüssiges aluminium mit einer
bestimmten temperatur von wasser
kontaktiert wird dann gibt es eine mega
explosion und es gibt die vermutung dass
eventuell die sprinkler die die
wasserspringer im gebäude angegangen
sind und auf das heißt der aluminium
getroffen sondern dadurch eine mega
explosion man hat auch explosionen kurz
vor dem zusammenbruch des gebäudes
gehört und das könnte das erklären dass
es da oben eine explosion gab dadurch
eine gesamte etage pulverisiert worden
ist und dadurch eben eine kettenreaktion
in gang gesetzt worden ist dass sie eine
nach der anderen
aber es ist halt dass das bei beiden
gebäuden gleichzeitig man kann da immer
wieder noch weiter in die tiefe gehen ja
also ich würde sagen da wir da wie er
dass es 1054 wissenschaftsnetz weg sind
dass sie auch wirklich bei der
wissenschaft bleiben
es lohnt sich jetzt nicht lange über so
etwas zu reden vor allem weil wir uns
darauf nicht vorbereitet habe und weil
es verschwörungstheoretikern eben auch
in den schoß fällt sondern ist sonst
eher über sachen zu reden wo wirklich
aktiv daran geforscht wird und wo man
sich fragen kann welche crane koopmann
an welche nicht und das habe ich
letztens übrigens mal ein
also ich poste wissenschaftliche kurz
fakten auf instagram dr wissenschaft
heißt ich da und dort habe ich letztens
so eine art anleitung gepostet wie man
denn vernünftig wissenschaftlicher
inhalte recherchiert und die meisten die
natürlich jetzt keine uni besucht haben
oder so wissen es nicht wie einfach man
an solche informationen kommen kann ja
ein tipp werde zum beispiel dass man
google scholar benutzt also die
wissenschaftliche suchmaschine von
google
die einen nur zu wissenschaftlichen
dokumenten führt und wo man wenn man es
wirklich genau wissen will und wenn man
sich in ein thema genau einarbeiten will
ja auf jeden fall einen blick drauf
werfen sollte anstatt sich nur focus.de
oder stern.de durchzulesen wo ja nichts
fix ist aber meine nur natürlich dass
man das auch journalisten fehler machen
können wenn sie eben nicht zum beispiel
vom fach sind
und das ist eben auch wissen dass es
medien gibt die eben
wissenschaftsredaktion dass medien gibt
die wissenschaftsredaktion einem extra
besitzen
und ja die wissen dass auch dass man das
so machen sollte und den tipp würde ich
auf jeden fall jedem geben der lust hat
sich wirklich tiefer in den aktuellen
forschungsstand von bestimmten thema
einzulesen
ebensolche wissenschaftliche
suchmaschinen zu benutzen wobei das
finde ich tatsächlich auch schwierig
weil ich habe dann tatsächlich hin und
hier die sache dass mir so einzelne
paper oder sonstwas geschickt werden
eben die wahrscheinlich über solche
suchmaschinen oder appartement oder
ähnliches gefunden wurden aber viele
leute tatsächlich das gar nicht mehr
passieren können es gibt studien dazu
dass
selbst gewisse prozentsätze an mediziner
in schwierigkeiten haben oder also hohe
prozentsätze kompliziertere studien
statistisch zu interpretieren
und da ist es tut mir leid statistik ist
leider nicht einfach für die nummer
person umso schwieriger und deshalb weiß
ich tatsächlich gar nicht ob man
wirklich den anspruch haben muss als
allgemein person wirklich zu jedem thema
sich so stadt ein lesen zu können oder
ob man nicht doch vielleicht überlegt
man vertraut hat den entsprechenden man
vertraut hat den entsprechenden experten
weil es gibt ja ich sage mal es gibt ja
mit zwischenlösungen dass es zum
beispiel spektrum der wissenschaft oder
sinex wo eben wissenschaftler oder
wissenschaftsjournalisten über
wissenschaftliche themen berichten da
sind übrigens auch immer die original
studio hast immer die original studien
verlinkt so dass man sich dann auch noch
mal in die original studien vertiefen
kann wenn man möchte aber ich sag mal so
manchmal sind die original studien echt
sehr sehr gut zu lesen und verständlich
manchmal sind die aber auch echt ein
extrem dickes brett und man kommt nicht
darin weiter aber auf eins zurück oder
ich will das noch mal verknüpfen was man
uns gesagt hat zum nine eleven
das ist genau der punkt dass man solche
themen nimmt aber daneben
wissenschaftlich überprüft und wirklich
nur die wissenschaftlichen aspekte eines
themas nimmt und zum beispiel einfach
mal alles raus lässt das fängt schon
damit an dass irgendeiner sache das
letzte mal schon mal raus dann lässt man
alles raus wenn es gibt ja zwischen
erich von däniken ist so auch ich weiß
gar nicht ob er noch lebt aber von von
von raumschiffen berichte die auf
unserer erde schon gelandet sind ein
experte
die auch aller mal raus lassen oder sie
unterhaltsam
ja der seltsam aber dass also die
wissenschaftlichen fakten nehmen oder
auch nur die von leuten die sich
auskennen
ich habe letztlich die per mail eine
diskussion mit einem wissenschaftler der
sich zum klimawandel und dann ein paar
tage später zu corona geäußert hat und
da in anführungszeichen
fachinformationen zu veröffentlicht hat
das nannte der fachinformation und dann
habe ich ihn gefragt wie er denn darauf
kommt und er hat am schluss argumentiert
ja auch jemand der mal einen kurs dazu
an der uni besucht hat darf sich dazu
äußern
und da wird's wirklich für mich auf der
hat überhaupt keine legitimation das
muss man wirklich sagen es gibt themen
ich sag mal newtons gesetze die kann man
vielleicht noch als layer vertreten
erklären und so weiter aber ich sage in
dem moment wo es ihnen denn das thema
klima geht klima ist hoch komplex da
geht es eben um gase wie co2
da geht es aber auch um physik da geht
es um biologie in borken sind bakterien
die arbeiten da geht es um so um chemie
es geht um so viele aspekte und wenn man
sich nicht ausführlich mit dem thema
beschäftigt hat ist man nicht dazu in
der lage auch nur das kleinste statement
zu fall zu äußern und dann auch noch die
dreistigkeit zu besitzen eine
information zu veröffentlichen das hat
mir wirklich die schuhe ausgezogen und
die socken dazu das war wirklich das
allerletzte also dass das finde ich halt
schlimme im netz dass ich weiß noch die
ersten begegnung mit krieg mit klima
skeptiker es jetzt gegen irgendein
ornithologe der meinte sich dazu äussern
dürfen also ein vorbild wissenschaftler
er hat nun gar keine ahnung von
klimawandel und so war es erschreckt
mich im netz immer wenn leute sich
erdreisten und das ist ja zum beispiel
jetzt bei corona und dieser freiheits
argumentation so was die leute haben von
tuten und blasen keine ahnung und wenn
irgendwo irgend jemanden in irgendeinem
chat irgendwas schreibt das schon als
beleg genutzt das ist einfach das ist
nicht nur unwissenschaftlich da fehlt
nicht nur in wissenschaft wissenschaft
dachten das ist das gegenteil
das ist also bewusst einfach die sachen
aus der luft greifen und sich irgendwas
dazu zusammenmixen das heißt halt gar
nichts
dieser ganze populären theorie als auch
dass bill gates alle tippen will und das
ist völlig aus der luft gegriffen die
haben irgendwie bericht gesehen dass
eben die bill gates stiftung gelder
locker machte impfungen in afrika und
machen dann daraus dass der eine zwangs
tippen möchte uns versklaven möchte und
da muss man auch wieder sein das ist
einfach irgendwie 30 meine liebe geld
ist wahrscheinlich der milliardär der
von seinem lehrer allermeisten gespendet
hat eine stiftung aufgebaut und dann
muss man ja nicht alle übereinstimmen
das ist ja diese schwarzen weiß nur
diesen menschen dann derart in die
pfanne zu hauen oder so das ist ja
wirklich ein philanthrop im buche steht
ist wie dreist vielleicht auch eine
gewisse art von neid dabei das kann auch
immer sein
also wenn ich will gates wäre würde ich
sagen komm doch das bistum hatte des
sohnes ist das was ich gemeint habe das
ist so eine verschwörungstheorie die
keine basis hat da gibt es keine physik
den man untersuchen kann
das ist so eine reine aufmerksamkeit
sache und das meinte ich von meinem
leben das ist eine der wenigen theorien
ist wo man vielleicht noch mal genauer
hinschauen kann weil da geht es um
physik und man kann es ja untersuchen
weil solche sachen wie jetzt mit bill
gates hat da hat vielleicht einer
irgendwann mal das behauptet ins
internet gestellt und dann ist es die
elektroleitungen
da können die leute das ist mal der
wahre kern wieder da haben wir auch
schon irgendwie wahrer kern ist manchmal
da sagen werde
wäre das auch bei den chips und auch ein
schlüssel ist dass wir jetzt eben für
impfungen einsetzen das ist der kern der
sache aber alles anders
aber ich kann sich kannst diese
verschwörungstheorie kann ich nicht
wissenschaftlich untersuchen das bild
ich eine zusage doch du kannst ja die
leute die gehen bordnetz die kannst du
dir nehmen dann essen wir machen was die
in ihrem blut haben und so weiter das
ist ja der wissenschaft da wird ja erst
mal eine theorie aufgestellt diese
theorie wird aus ich sag mal messungen
studio oder satz gewonnen beispielsweise
es gibt hier eine galerie in galaxien
cluster und da sind 36 galaxien drin und
das das hat man einfach man hat
verschiedene messungen dazu genommen und
dann hat man guckt was ist sie weit
entfernt und dann hat man diese theorie
aufgestellt und dann fängt wissenschaft
erst an dann kommt wissenschaft und
überprüft stimmt das was spricht dafür
was spricht dagegen was können wir alles
für gegen theesen aufbauen falsche
messungen galaxien sind gar nicht so nah
und so weiter und dass wissenschaft
wissenschaft stellt erst mal eine these
auf und überprüft sie dann wenn diese
überprüfung immer mehr belege dafür
liefern dass diese theorie stimmt erst
dann ist das eine belegte theorie und
beim verschwörungstheorien
da wird irgendwas zusammengesammelt
daraus wird irgendeine these aufgebaut
und diese these wird sofort als wahrheit
behauptet und das ist der riesige
unterschied
und das ist nicht an erstellt und an man
könnte es ja hier überprüfen also bill
gates spielt gern auch gehen auch eine
rolle in dieser art in oak room sache
kann vielleicht martin mehr zu sagen es
wäre ganz einfach überprüfbar ist dieses
stoffwechselprodukt achim krombach das
genick jung und wird nur hinreichend
konsumiert doch das existiert sogar
martin aber das ist nicht so wie die
behaupten weil ich möchte mal sagen
adriano chrome kann man auf gereinigt im
internet kaufen ja da das muss man nicht
irgendwo raus gewinnen so viel dazu
nicht mehr sagen ich glaub ich hab mich
ein bisschen in der falle weil das ist
finde ich etwas was man erinnert oder
woran man denken muss man ist nicht als
sozusagen in der diskussion mit
verschwörungstheoretikern man ist nicht
selbst in der pflicht diese thesen ja
nur widerlegen
sondern die leute müssen müssten
eigentlich ihre thesen selbst weisen
deshalb fange ich auch solche diskussion
mit den leuten gar nicht an ja weil also
insbesondere wenn das so gewisse
physikalisch oder chemische grundlagen
hat aber die eben letztendlich von
diesen leuten verdreht sind ist es
unglaublich schwierig mit diesen leuten
zu diskutieren und weil man eben nicht
wirklich argumentieren kann ja mal die
argumente nicht angenommen werden
und da ist es eben glaube ich eigentlich
nicht gut wenn man sagt so wie müssen
oder wir versuchen jetzt zu beweisen
dass die gäste es eben nicht gemacht hat
da andere nur anders um diese leute
müssen eigentlich erst mal beweisen
nachweisen dass dem so ist und das
können sie an ich tatsächlich aber
martin überhaupt also mein taxi die
diese these aufstellen da hingehen
müssen und einen untersuchen müssen der
eben gegen worden ist die müssen dass
die müssen eine wissenschaftliche
untersuchung machen und untersuchen ob
die chips drin sind und wenn sie das
beweisen können dann dürfen sie diese
theorie gerne vertreten aber solange sie
das nicht beweisen können können sie
diese theorie nicht vertreten das ist
genau der punkt wir müssen eben nicht
nachweisen dass ihre thesen nicht stimmt
sondern sie müssen nachweisen dass ihre
thesen stimmen und das funktioniert der
nie egal ob sie mondlandung ist alle
argumente kannst du ganz wunderbar
entkräften
ob es die klare erde ist alle argumente
kannst du wunderbar entkräften und so
weiter und so fort die müssen beweisen
genau ich lasse mich auch nicht auf die
diskussion ein
sondern ich liefert den beweis dass es
anders ist und wenn die leute dann
meinen arbeiten weiter zu argumentieren
dann höre ich immer auf und sorgen und
ja unter punkt sondern im flachen erde
kommentar einblenden lassen das ist ja
der versucht ist der op sehr gern davon
gehe um ein geben wir uns noch in sehr
gut herkommt sagt er
denn das ist eigentlich klassische
beweis dass verteidigung bewegt wie
schon gesagt habt also in der juristerei
ist es ganz klar eine behauptung
aufstellt er musste quasi auch belegen
das heißt wenn ich sage auf der
rückseite vormals lebten picker elefant
wird und wäre es an mir diese behauptung
zugelegen größten schweißt manchmal hört
ist das bestimmt nicht hört man mich
wieder nicht 12 12 vielen dank an casas
oft für die spende und größe in die
schweiz
also ich finde das super das hat man
noch nie im chat ich will als ganz ganz
toll
ich glaube da machen wir damit müssen
wir überlegen was wir damit machen
ich rechne mal am ende zusammen und dann
machen wir irgendwas besonderes mit ist
diskutieren ja gleich noch ich würde
sagen soll also um 10 24 minuten
ascot gehen habt ihr noch lust wird
definitiv geben
der link wird gleich wieder eingeblendet
und ja jetzt den kommentar das würde
mich mal interessieren
zum thema flache erde besprochen dass
wir gleich sehen ich bin mal gespannt ob
es um kurz zu sehen
prévals japan taktischen ja ich habe den
ganzen ordner mit solchen kommentaren
ich habe weil ich habe da auch nicht
angefangen zu diskutieren aber ich
machte mir abgesprochen habe ich hatte
irgendwie verwendung werde ich
dazwischen doch haben und jetzt in
diesem weißt du bist so weit also der
link zum disco server ist unten in der
video beschreibung das war mal wieder
tollen grafik zeigen und hier ist der
kommentar geht ihr die kommentare sie
denn er ist da war er damit als ich auch
jetzt soll ich immer wieder von lesen
ist das schon mal ein video ist diesmal
vor also die erde ist nach mit firmament
ihr blöden gelogen was ist das denn ihr
seid sowieso von dämonen besessen
deswegen sagt ihr blind augen auf nach
oben schauen wo ist die sonne und mond
kostenlos mit ball statt hollywood
computeranimation es ist wenn das die
wortschöpfung bloßen fünf fantastisch
wir sind alle groß und so und hier
übrigens noch viele grüße in die schweiz
weil ich gerade den euro bekommen nach
österreich nach österreich in österreich
tschuldigung schuldig was rede ich denn
davon versprechen nach österreich an den
doppelten strange wenn ich das richtig
lese mein schatz hat der
verletzungsserie sophisticated ja auch
schon andere kommentar finde ich dass er
sagt schaut mal nach oben wo sind denn
sonne und mond
sie sind ja offensichtlich noch mal
darüber nach oben schaut und wie
aufwändig die frage etwa versuchen sonne
und mond zu widerlegen
dann muss man sagen manchmal ist auch
die einfachste begründung die ware zum
beispiel gibt es den mond ja war die
mode l'oréal
ja denn die gegen behauptung die montan
dabei war gefaked es viel schwieriger zu
darzulegen
als einfach zu akzeptieren dass es so
war deswegen kann man das sonst
zusammenfasst man sollte nicht alles
blind glauben man sollte aber nur dort
fertig sein
sexismus an
tracht ist aber noch ein das ist ja der
wahnsinn selbst gerade wieder dem mit
dem jetzt kommt man nur was soll ich
dazu noch sagen genauso da wo es skepsis
angebracht ist und das ist wieder eine
bildungsfrage genau was wir eben schon
angesprochen hatten
damit die leute wissen wo sie skeptisch
sein müssen müssen sie eine gute bildung
erhalten und dass das sind wir in
deutschland glaube ich ganz gut da war
ich sage ja tatsächlich die
verschwörungstheoretiker glaube ich ich
habe einen medizinischen bereich oder
was die nutzung an alternativen medizin
angeboten angeht ist ja auch nicht aus
dem unteren sozioökonomischen feld
sondern durchaus auch wo ich hoffe jetzt
hat sich nicht etwas kontaktiert bei mir
durchaus glaube ich auch teilweise aus
dem gehobenen also ich weiß nicht und so
ist
ich glaube dass jetzt nicht dazu aber es
gibt ja die berühmten sinus milieus wo
man so guckt das sind zum beispiel also
bestimmte bevölkerungsgruppen die
einfach auf eine art drauf sind das sind
zum beispiel die bürgerlichen ökos oder
die keine ahnung rechten weiß weiß ich
also es gibt bestimmte milieus und da
habe ich den eindruck das sind ganz
verschiedene das sind eben die
bildungsfernen aber wie ihr gerade
gehört habe ich habe auch mit
wissenschaftlern zu tun die
verschwörungstheorien anhängen und das
ist den vollkommen egal
das ist einmal ist es eben der
klimawandel und zwei wochen später
verließ auch einfach information zum
corona virus also das ist das sind alte
weiße saure männer also die einfach
keine ahnung enttäuscht vom leben sind
das sind aber ich glaube enttäuschung
spielt eine große rolle die
wissenschaftlerin mit der ich gesprochen
habe
lamberti die meinte auch ich gebe das
etwa wieder das was ich an spielen
das ist es ein weg eine einzigartige
einzigartigkeit
zu erreichen hey ich bin ja so schlau
ich bin da sehr skeptisch und ich glaube
das alles nicht und das ist ja wie
wahrscheinlicher die definieren sich
dadurch und ja das ist glaube ich ein
ganz wichtiger punkt ohne wir haben ja
dann spielen das war kurz ein
wenn es den motor den hätten wir gerne
gegangen ist oder doch nicht nur das
bild aber dann kommt nicht christoph ich
würde dazu ganz gern noch mal was sagen
ja bitte also wodurch sich
verschwörungstheorien oder verschwörungs
mythen heraus zeichnen ist das immer so
redet radikal sind dass sie eigentlich
das komplette weltbild umwerfen wollen
so woran erkennt man einen seriösen
wissenschaft ein seriöser
wissenschaftler versucht die welt nicht
mit einer studie um zu werfen sondern er
erklärt welche welche fehler seine
studie besitzen er ist reflektiert genug
um zu sagen es könnte vielleicht seien
hier gibt es starke beweise dass es so
sein können das wissen wir noch nicht
und er stellt weitere fragen so dass das
ist vielleicht der unterschied weil wir
reden jetzt die ganze zeit darüber ja
keine ahnung zum teil wird sich auch
schon lustig über leute gemacht aber wir
müssen vielleicht mal darüber sprechen
wo durch erkennt man es und wenn du
schon sagst es gibt auch wissenschaftler
die an komischen theorien glauben wem
kann man jetzt vertrauen und woran liegt
es also ich würde schon sagen dass es
ein starkes indiz ist dass jemand
vertrauenswürdig ist
wenn er eben reflektiert genug ist um zu
sagen ich will die welt jetzt nicht mit
meiner aussage umwerfen sondern ich
versuche das vielleicht einen kleinen
schritt in eine andere richtung zu gehen
und so funktioniert wissenschaft
eigentlich auch die studien jeden tag
werden 100 studien veröffentlicht wenn
ich tausende und sie gehen immer nur
einen kleinen schritt und die gesamtheit
der studien die machen dann vielleicht
den wissenschaftlichen konsens oder bzw
das was wir vielleicht wahrheit oder
beziehungsweise das gegenteil von
verschwörungstheorien
du hast ja auch ganz interessant es gibt
ja auch themen wo kein
wissenschaftlicher konsens der winzer
wie sie nun das master haben vor ein
paar jahren noch alle gesagt ist es
nicht möglich oder nicht alle ist super
unwahrscheinlich und was ihr da macht
ist unwissenschaftlich und jetzt mit
dabei dachte ich das komplett gedreht
und die meisten sagen es ist möglich das
zeigt ja auch dass wissenschaft leben in
bewegung ist und sich das ändern kann
und und auch die herrschende meinung ist
immer die gleiche ist richtig und wenn
wir noch mal auf drosten eingehen
natürlich sobald wir den namen nennen
der typ ist der polarisiert mich nicht
von sich aus sondern eben weil die weil
die meinung da so stark auseinandergehen
und es ist eben auch zur soweit drosten
wenn man ihm zuhört er versucht schon
deine fehler zu korrigieren die er
vielleicht im letzten podcast gemacht
hat oder wenn es eben eine neue studie
gibt die auf etwas anderes hin deutet im
gegensatz zu vielen verschwörungs mit
lernen wie wir sie jetzt einfach mal
nennen die immer auf ihrer meinung
beharren und die quasi nur argumente für
sich suchen aber sich nicht damit
auseinandersetzen was sind eigentlich
falsch an ihren argumenten sein
ja das ist klassische cherry picking von
studien also dass man zum beispiel auch
zu gewissen themen nur studie darauf
sucht die die eigene sozusagen meinung
unterstützen
und tatsächlich wie du gesagt hast ein
sein da ändern seiner meinung aufgrund
eben von evidenz aufgrund neuer studie
jetzt sozusagen studien haben ja
dementsprechend auch unterschiedliche
evidenz gerade eine studie die mit ein
paar sachen im labor gemacht wurde ist
kein vergleich zu einem seiner
systematischen analyse multipler cities
zum beispiel also sind als wenn du meist
controlled trials also an menschen mit
entsprechend doppelt verblindete placebo
kontrollierte studien die natürlich ein
ganz anderes level letztendlich an
ergebnissen daraus bringen als eine
studie in der man zum beispiel nur
rückblickend auf gewisse fall serien zu
was das ist auch noch mal finde ich
einfach mal ganz wichtigen punkt was du
gesagt hast dass wissenschaft eben nicht
an einer bestätigung interessiert ist
und diese studien um wirklich die
wirkung zum beispiel von medikamenten zu
überprüfen die sind nicht darauf
ausgerichtet die wirkung zu bestätigen
und obwohl das pharmaunternehmen machen
die ja ein medikament verkaufen wollen
sind sie eben zu doppelblindstudien
verpflichtet das heißt sie unabhängig
von den chancen kommt bei solchen
studien heraus ob ein medikament wirkt
oder nicht und bei chloroquin zum
beispiel hat sich das in den letzten
wochen ja herausgestellt dass dieses
medikament an malaria medikament oder
was früher gegen malaria eingesetzt
worden ist dass es eben entgegen den
ersten berichten den ersten studien dazu
nicht wirkt und das ist eben
wissenschaft das ist ein riesiger
unterschied ob ich eben meine these
vertreten will und da gibt es halt auch
in der wissenschaft leute die suche nach
diesen die sie unterstützen und oder
eben ob ich das ständig wieder überprüfe
und in frage stelle
und nur so kann wissenschaft
funktionieren und wir als eben
wissenschafts kanäle das auch noch mal
zur information wir versuchen eben diese
studien zu finden
es kann natürlich sein dass wenn man
eine einzelne studie heraus stellen aber
wir versuchen in großem bogen eben immer
herauszufinden was ist wirklich wohin
geht die forschung was ist das ergebnis
wie entwickeln sich quantenrechner wird
kernfusion irgendwann mal kommt und ich
sage man natürlich mit auch einer mit
einem hintergrund aber eben doch ohne
studien aus der luft gegriffen wie sich
jetzt zum beispiel alkohol zeigt scheint
die wärme da überhaupt gar nichts zu
machen es ist eben anders bei als bei
gruppen oder grippalen infekten
die gehen halt gerne bei wärme weg
jedenfalls santa corona macht es eben
nicht und das ist der unterschied
zwischen wissenschaft ja meiner also von
mir aus können wir jetzt gerne mal ich
würde das ja gerne ausprobieren mit
disco
eure meinung dazu wenn man darüber gehen
würde sagen ja das machen weil ich fand
es echt super wir haben hier viele
aspekte gesprochen wir haben auch nie
schreibt übrigens doctor strange freue
mich schon zusammen auf die rechnung
alles für die wissenschaft ja wirklich
super also nochmal allen spenderinnen
und spendern die im chat hier auf
youtube was da gelassen haben
wir können wirklich da was mit anfangen
und wir fangen was damit an in denen wir
eben wissenschaft unterstützen und nicht
um wissenschaft und das waren wir jetzt
weiter auf disco der link ist und in der
video beschreibung direkt der erste satz
einfach draufklicken und da geht es
jetzt weiter
ich gucke ob dann chatraum chatraum
einen chatraum für uns offen ist und da
gehen wir rein und wir schreiben auch
mit und so weiter und so fort
ich freue mich euch also absolut oder
ich freue mich auf euch auf disc ort
also bis dann bleib dran und dann kann
euch alle hier machen ist an